now we can return to our story Alice and
Bob have split and must communicate from
a distance in order to arrange their
next steps
however Eve is able to intercept their
letters so they need to disguise their
meaning the following analogy is helpful
first Alice locks her message in a box
with a lock that only her and Bob have
the combination to this is known as
encryption then she sends the box to Bob
knowing that it is safe since nobody
else knows the combination when Bob
receives the box he unlocks it and reads
the message this is known as decryption
cryptography begins when we perform
encryption and decryption with virtual
locks instead of physical ones these are
known as ciphers this first well-known
cipher a substitution cipher was used by
Julius Caesar around 58 BC it's now
referred to as the Caesar cipher during
the war Caesar shifted each letter in
his military commands in order to make
them appear meaningless should the enemy
intercepted imagine Alice and Bob
decided in advance to communicate using
the Caesar cipher with the shift of
three first Alice writes her message in
plain English then she applies a shift
of three to each letter so a becomes D B
becomes e C becomes F and so on this
unreadable or encrypted message is then
sent to Bob openly
[Music]
then Bob simply subtracts the shift of
three from each letter in order to read
the original message incredibly this
basic cipher was used by military
leaders for hundreds of years after
Caesar and one but I haven't conquered
over man's fear which is indomitable
however a lock is only as strong as its
weakest point a lot breaker may look for
mechanical flaws or failing that extract
information in order to narrow down the
correct combination block breaking and
code breaking are very similar the true
weakness of the Caesar cipher was
published 800 years later by an arab
mathematician named al Kindi he broke
Caesar cipher by using a clue based on
an important property of the language
and message is written if you scan text
from any book and count the frequency of
each letter you will find a fairly
consistent pattern for example these are
letter frequencies of English this can
be thought of as the fingerprint of
English we leave this fingerprint when
we communicate without realizing it this
clue is one of the most valuable tools
for a codebreaker to break this cipher
they count up the frequencies of each
letter in the encrypted text and check
how far the fingerprint has shifted if
age is the most popular letter instead
of e that the shift was likely three
they reverse the shift in order to
reveal the message this was a blow to
the Caesar cipher but it didn't stop
people from developing stronger ciphers
a strong cipher is one which disguises a
fingerprint this fingerprint is a result
of unique letter frequencies within a
language
you
[Music]
to make a lighter fingerprint is to
flatten this distribution of letter
frequencies by the mid 15th century we
had advanced polyalphabetic ciphers to
accomplish this imagine Alice and Bob
have shared secret shift word first
Alice converts the word into numbers
according to the letter position in the
alphabet next this sequence of members
is repeated along the message
finally each letter in the message is
encrypted by shifting according to the
number below it
[Music]
then the encrypted message is sent
openly to Bob Bob decrypt the message by
subtracting the shifts according to the
secret word he also has a copy of now
imagine a codebreaker
Eve she intercepts a series of messages
and calculates the letter frequencies
she will find a flatter distribution a
lighter fingerprint hmm how could she
break this remember cold Breakers look
for an information link the same is
finding a partial fingerprint anytime
there is a differential in letter
frequencies a leak of information occurs
this difference is caused by any
repetition in the encrypted message in
this case this cipher suffers from the
repetition of the shift word to break
the encryption Eve would first need to
determine the length of the shift word
used not the word itself when she checks
the frequency distribution of every 5th
letter the fingerprint will reveal
itself the problem now is to break 5
Caesar ciphers in a repeating sequence
individually this is a trivial task as
we have seen before so for over 400
years the problem remained how could
Alice design a cipher that hides her
fingerprint thus stopping the leak of
information the answer is randomness
think of this Alice rolls a twenty six
sided dice to generate a list of random
shifts and shares this with Bob instead
of a shift word now to encrypt your
message Alice uses this list of random
shifts instead it is important that this
list of shifts be as long as the message
as to avoid any repetition then she
sends it to Bob who decrypts the message
by using the same list of random numbers
she had given him now Eve will have a
problem because the resulting encrypted
message will have two powerful
properties one the shifts never fall
into a repetitive pattern and two the
encrypted message will have a uniform
frequency distribution because there is
no frequency differential and therefore
no leak it is now impossible for Eve to
break the encryption this is the
strongest possible method of encryption
and it emerged towards the end of the
19th century it is now known as the
one-time pad to understand the true
power of this method consider the
following experiment to visualize the
strength of the one-time pad we must
understand the explosion of
possibilities for example the Caesar
cipher shifted every letter by the same
amount which was some number between 1
and 26 if Alice was to encrypt your name
it would result in one of 26 possible
encryptions a small number of
possibilities now compare this to the
one-time pad where each letter would be
shifted by a different number between 1
and 26 the number of possible
encryptions is 26 multiplied by itself 5
times almost 12 million this could be
hard to visualize
so imagine she wrote her name on a
single page and on top of it stacked
every possible encryption how high would
it be with almost 12 million five letter
sequences this stack of paper would be
enormous
over 1 kilometer high
when Alice encrypts your name using the
one-time pad it is the same as picking
one of these pages at random this is
perfect secrecy in action
you